Korean powerhouse SK Telecom t1 will
play in the 2017 lck summer playoff
finals making it the fourth consecutive
lck final that jungler peanut will be in
being the only LT gate player to achieve
this at the moment we put together the
best of peanuts so far in his career
[Music]
going on here sky and some trouble takes
a big chunk out of Kuro there's a
gravity starting right now peanut should
get at first blood over to the Tigers
and Kuro gets out with six no are you
kidding me trying to get away has flash
he does you could flash get to and
waiting for that arcane shift there it
is they get him they knew exactly
they're looking for there's a kill on to
bang nicely played by peanut Olympic
visions all that good stuff
score going in on a peanut we're getting
a bit low though you're not looking for
his first kill flash up score flasher
peanut and there is the battle ward
it's supposed to be costly can't even
bounce away the no flash Merisi they get
a hell of a lot of damage Pino goes in
deep mines the kill and now it's looking
for another one flashes it on the ruler
jumps on table and that's gonna be a
double kill from peanut this is why you
don't give him diddly meanwhile the
backside of the fight the Emperor's
divide comes out here from but it's not
batter it's a triple kill now from
peanut look under Quattro can he find it
no Kuro I'm gonna take that one away
with the piercing arrow but Rox Tigers
are gonna come out on top thirty one and
a half minutes here inna done Italy
another MVP
Oh peanut finds max oh my god wow he got
me pepper 8y gonna try to turn
they take the turret kill already for
prey out to the turret goes down Kuro on
the run gorilla comes in on the fly
score in trouble in the 1v3 he's going
to get taken out meanwhile prey gets
another one on to fly
peanut back in with the ultimate again
arrow the last man standing this group
of players that have either retired or
been rejected by other teams comes in no
big sponsor no big team house it's not
necessary because they are going to way
they'll seek a summer and they are going
to get a spot in Worlds again there it
is brunch Tigers taken gg it's about
time and that is it
they finally over
first first place these bears
congratulations
doesn't always have the anybody gets
into the rocks Tigers win the big one
they go to Louis education the two years
of suffering and the cheers
guys I mean again
you need the infrastructure to win
tournaments to say that you need the big
money in the fancy team house to get to
the world to make a difference man look
at these guys they practice hard they're
dedicated it took up two years they are
champions like a surgeon asked how do
you feel and you know she can I explain
it's something that no one can no one
can actually understand unless you win
title it's really really kind of
dazzling you don't know what to say
I think this guy is the best
pressure jungler in the world I think
what peanut can bring to the early game
is absolutely insane
yes he's so young you know he's so fresh
you still trying a lot of crazy things
here and there and sometimes it does
backfire for him but when you put him on
a jungle away you can invade the enemy
jungle and like level 3 level 4 and you
can put some pressure on the top side
with Smith he is outstanding and no one
can actually match him that way
today it's wisdom as all okay winning
Monaco in the day
it's a [ __ ] buddy to me hang on my
father two minutes
y'all get stop wishing me a car Angus
all calm down touching on the rock wall
take care brother Todd Watson in car
I think Smith maybe caught one is Luke
the peanut here he's gonna keep this
verdict him out of the way peanut does
dodged that one but the sun's gonna keep
him against the wall tonight he's coming
me nuts looking for it smoking a try
keep him up here what's it the Navy I
can't Peter
[Applause]
lady gonna tower they got a tower oh
this game is so Gracie I can't believe
it and they got elder drink get away
yeah it's like we talked about when the
Sheng gets those mr items like what do
you do like even if your rumbles fair if
you mess apparently you glad to kill
here take a drink pina now it's not
peanut to try seal his ultimate is up in
about ten seconds yeah I think he's
gonna look for it they don't wanna fall
this far behind praise going in will he
try for the steel peanuts going for the
funded for Rox Tigers they are lady
better as the team
but the reengagement gorilla means
nothing to go steadily peanut is here on
the Olaf a flash portion out of my love
but he is still chasing on the deaf
who's nearly out of HP the chasing on
prey first blood two for PETA it might
be a third and they're re-engaged for
koro1 can he do much of anything it
doesn't seem like a lot peanut very very
low boiling from Spence's don't you dare
go for my team base another one Rox
Tigers four to one question Baron music
well thought out by Roxas Plata started
minutes events
just like the previous game it's still
rocks in a bit of a bowl scale is still
there that's all the damage peanut these
millimeters down as well five before
keep on going peanut just exquisitely
simply right there burning the arcane
shift of his first sonic wave and then
killing him on the second one that was
just perfect and it's exactly what rocks
needed to continue to push in also worth
noting and sort of sort of par for the
course is didn't cut a little forth
here's the judgment a few more attacks
will do it and that's that starting item
that sort of build from the chimp but
they're gonna spin out yet again
beautiful shockwave set up by faker you
know leaps in over the wall here we go
we got the Baron started and now it's
definitely a time for peanut to pull out
all the stops and go for the miracle
spike candy got it it's gonna run in and
oh yeah he gets the boat somehow and now
bang is getting ultimate in here so
maybe they can turn here comes Baker
though trying to come on in and once he
comes it's gonna be so much damage out
into the pipe but look at the burst
damage enemy and it's not going to be
enough though and so many members of
MVPs super low you know jumping out of
that Prost over and over and over again
at least our just went up they will have
plenty of damage in fertile and mountain
Drake all being amplified by the elder
dragon bomb comes out
great up flashes over the ass Cheryl
comes up with a steal proto ship will
keep him alive for now but can he make
it out of the pit with draws over pops
up by the depth charge he should go down
in this but peanut the hero play my god
takes away the Barris rhyming here to
try to keep this turret alive
by Potiphar's here cut away from you
they don't pop up
six one and four now witness brave
splashing and lateral damage a share of
coming fruit yeah that's a malware go
take some out another one seven one
enforcement or jump questions away
trying to keep some alive the castle not
going to connect them from Mooney they
didn't also see that warden the backs of
hit their pink ward is too far up so
they didn't know that's keep the and
vision and SKT is here to content food
et P in peanut on the side looking to
throw Daisy in flashes in for this one
the Baron and now the fight from escaped
d2 w e9 v 7 looking to separate it but
he's already used the ultimate and Daisy
now splits the team's his first hits are
going to be the one that counted Connie
and she ain't first the flash out of the
pit
nine five seven in the front mystic has
shots from the side but he's not putting
it any damage just yet
remember the goats and effects of the
gold lead this is King about Marines
proving it peanut with a disengage
ultimate follows him with this sonic
wave in the resonating strike the record
is broken now hoody overheating with the
flames pizza he's looking to get another
defensive flash they're actually doing
it the king of every disease after
lepers are about to ace SKT they're
gonna tell
through the portal 2:15 kill the game
and that's it for the game it's Kay
telecom knock over the second Nexus
turret 46 kills remain seated beside
2017 penis what got into you there that
was absolutely insist upon by our
opponents they're super aggressive and
by counteracting their moves
I just got killed by one kill at one
after and actually they got stronger and
I think that lets my performance
continue to exert the damage shaft but
medley could be next up surfers
we're gonna trade kill for one bus
recruiting out of Alvin's and can't get
much down either first enough to make a
little bit of vengeance on this one but
he's still on the chase he not as well
the killer comes in triple but against
Katie jugular veins will be felled and
his next up with a chopping block he
can't get away from this one to lock it
down as the best team in the world and
SKT are once again the champions
on it looks like score trying to come in
the arrows gonna hit pause right at the
right second step now is getting stunned
up handing it onto the exhaust coming
down they are on the taste lacing
Maelstrom another stun comes in and
there is the reksai ultimate to clean up
the kill
hello we're coming in look at how low
this turret is already bless making his
way
here's peanut trying to make it a two on
two and they will get that tempt
flashing away Baker getting their
riftwalk and he does come on in it's not
gonna be arriving in time to stop the
baron from going down to the battle the
feast is now rather promised map to go
ahead and confirm that one made from
scrap SKT one following through and tar
goes in its advanced down in on the
score but now he's isolated heroes
entrance will help keep alive them all
but this faker gets a decent pop up
couple members taunted in a Smith goes
low and this Creed the turnaround that
SK keep desperately needs
smeb will go down so far nobody else on
the side of KT has been taken out but
scores on the wrong side of the map SK
Telecom in the semi-final they're going
on the play against logs you a week from
today and so reverse sweep bringing it
back in they Wed 3.2 SKT will face off
against long zoo gaming and the lck
finals
well peanut helped SKT win another
championship title let us know what you
think in the comment section below
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button
[Music]